خطوات جديه اتخذتها الولايات المتحده
لتنظيم قطاع الذكاء الاصطناعي حيث تدرس
حاليا واشنطن وضع قوانين تنظم ادوات
الذكاء الاصطناعي وتتيح للبيت الابيض وضع
كوابح على التقنيات الجديده مثل تشات
تاتي هذه الخطوه لتشير لانفتاح البيت
الابيض على وضع بعض القواعد الاساسيه في
هذا المجال خاصه وان بايدن صرح سابقا بانه
لا يوجد حكم نهائي فيما اذا كان الذكاء
الاصطناعي يشكل خطرا على المجتمع حيث حظ
بايدن الكونغرس على تمرير قوانين تضع
قيودا صارمه على شركات التكنولوجيا الضخمه
لكن فرصه احراز اي تقدم تبدو ضئيله في ظل
الانقسامات السياسيه بين المشرعين
الامريكيين رغم ان الولايات المتحده
مشاهدينا هي موطن اكبر شركات التكنولوجيا
بما في ذلك شركه اوبن اي التي انشات
الا انها متاخره دوليا في مج الانظمه التي
ترعى هذا القطاع حيث ادى افتقار الولايات
المتحده للتشريعات اللازمه الى اعطاء
سيليكون فالي حريه طرح منتجات جديده
للذكاء الاصطناعي دون التحقق من تاثيرها
وقبل طبعا ان تتمكن الحكومه الامريكيه من
وضع القوانين اللازمه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات